struggling to walk after more than a
month at Sea survivors of the latest
migrant boat to capsize off the West
African Coast have now been taken to
safety on the island of Sal in Cape Fear
days
the survivors are better they're being
hydrated they're being looked after here
in the tent here at the port in terms of
testing we're testing for malaria and
covet and so far we haven't had any
positives
just over 100 people are believed to
have been on the fishing boat when it
left the Senegalese Coast in early July
a large number of them are now dead
relatives in the small village of fast
boys say they were trying to make their
way to Spain
it comes with a lot of pain yes but we
know that migration issues are Global
issues which require International
cooperation a lot of discussion and
Global strategy given what the world is
going through right now with migratory
issues it means that we all all the
nations have to sit down at the table
and see what we can do so that we don't
lose any more lives at Sea above all
the journey to Europe from West Africa
is one of the world's most dangerous
migrant Roots it typically ends in the
Canary Islands as Spanish archipelago
off the coast of Northwestern Africa
nearly 600 people died while making the
crossing last year this latest attempt
ended off Cape Verde and with 15
shipwrecks already recorded on the route
this year it's unlikely that it'll be
long before more lives are lost in this
stretch of ocean Alex beard Al Jazeera
thank you